you know to pursue a filmmaking career
the way that we do we have to have faith
that one day our effort is going to pan
out the reality is that is that it's
probably not going to pan out do you
ever think about about that side of it
about like you know what all this work
it's never ever going to pan out and
sort of how do you what do you do or how
do you keep your faith strong you have
to love it to begin with if you're doing
it because you see it as a way to make
money you see it as like your meal
ticket then I don't think you're going
to be successful but you know if it's
something that you love and you're
passionate about then you know what if
it pens helping near 95 then great
that's just an added bonus you know if
you're able to make something from it or
if you're able to to you know like get
to a certain point like great like
that's a bonus but i think it's the
process of making it that it's so
rewarding to begin with so you know
seeing a final product and like putting
yourself all in is is not something that
a lot of people do like outside of this
world where you just you go for it and
and seeing a product completed is such a
rewarding thing like even if it's even
if it's just kind of like I mean even if
you don't make all of your money back
from it or whatever but having that
final thing of like you know I did that
like I put that together and watching
that is enough to be able to want to do
it again um but yeah you have to love it
you have to be kind of crazy about
loving it too yeah I think I think it
comes in phases I think there's a point
where you know there's a drive to when
you're younger like you have to like get
all these milestones and you have to be
you must be this famous or can't
continue or must be this successful and
can't continue and I think the more you
do it if you love it um you're going to
keep doing it and I mean at least for me
the goal is is to chip away you know get
a little be a little more successful
every time
and you know if it was if it was
something that I was going to stop based
on where I'm at now then I don't think I
don't think we would be finishing our
Kickstarter if I have that type of
mentality um but but I don't and I'm
happy with where I'm at in terms of
growing as a filmmaker and hopefully
being able to get to a point where um I
can see the rewards of that success
playoff so I think it's is taking it up
levels and where where I'm at now and
where we're at now I think I think we're
on a good pace and I think you do need
to re-examine but I think for me it
would be re-examined what I'm doing
within that creative sphere rather than
not being within that crazy yeah and I
think that sort of what it comes down to
you know it's like like if you mean
maybe it's because we're not quitters
you know but it's like that idea of like
okay like I'm gonna quit I'm not gonna
do that anymore like where does that
leave you the cool so you're just gonna
go your nine to five and be unhappy and
miserable for the rest of your life like
that's ones like a great decision like
that like that doesn't make sense this
idea of like I'm just not gonna do it
anymore i'm done with it I'm like I I
just don't understand it um I don't know
maybe maybe I haven't been frustrated
anything up or whatever but it's like I
feel like it's always going to be
something there may be a frustration or
there's going to be like something else
that you pursue for a what real for a
little while but I feel like if it's
something you're really passionate
you're always going to keep coming back
to it it's not like if an opportunity
comes down four years down the road
after you've quit you're gonna be like
no no I don't do that anymore they say
don't yeah i think you know even to be
successful in a nine-to-five you have to
have a certain level of drive so why not
applied that drive to do something you
have a passion part of something you
love doing if you have a drive to be
successful then you know they're gonna
be frustrations and there are going to
be ups and downs in anything you do I'm
so it I mean at least it's in something
that we love doing and then mean
how many how many years has has has been
a
of yours um for for a long time I think
I started later um and maybe that's why
I have that perspective because I went
to school as an econ major in that that
completely didn't work out at all um but
that's a completely different story um
but you know I wrote stories when I was
a kid and realized that that that's
where my passion was and so in college I
kind of came back to it as a
screenwriter and then as a filmmaker and
have had that drive ever since and it
hasn't waned it's been pretty strong
since she should have rediscovered it oh
yeah it hasn't in fact it's honestly
that that drive has helped me through
through more difficult and challenging
every everyday life more than you know
it being too to my detriment I think
there is big enough passion to pull me
into a minute it's like a black hole of
I don't know
you